[Music]
you know been thinking a lot recently
about this idea of kind of the
marketplace of ideas you know in civics
class we learned that this is the way
that the truth kind of comes to the top
that the best ideas displace the worst
ideas but I kind of think it's a better
metaphor than it intends to be in the
sense that marketplaces as any economist
will tell you are not necessarily the
place where the best product comes to
the top there are all sorts of dynamics
that determine who wins and in fact you
know if you follow disruption theory
which is in vogue in in Silicon Valley
that's all about how actually a worse
product can beat a better product in the
marketplace we have a marketplace of
ideas in the bad sense of that term not
the good sense of that term where you
know what wins in the marketplace may
not be fair may not be right and
certainly may not be true but it's based
on this very reductive set of rules of
supply and demand
you know we're all trying to grapple
right now with what that means when
there are less kind of institutional
gatekeepers who are holding in check
which ideas are competing with which
other ones but it turns out that you
know ideas that there are ideas that are
very appealing and very contagious that
are either completely untrue or that are
appealing to you know our worst
instincts about each other nobody wants
some random person off the internet to
do their brain surgery right like
experts have a place in our society and
journalism is a form of expertise and I
think that's gotten obscured by a couple
of things one is that journalism is
often presented right alongside opinion
content and that's actually really
confusing to people and so I think
audiences have come to sort of like see
some of this content actually isn't
expert expertly developed content and or
it isn't developed according to this
specific expert process and some of it
is and I can't tell the difference so
I'm gonna kind of downgrade my
assessment of the whole profession the
trust that we've put in a lot of these
institutions
I think legitimately has been misplaced
or it's been you know I think there are
ways in which big media institutions
have not truly had the interests of
their readers or viewers at heart you
have to acknowledge that in order to get
to winning back that trust and I don't
think there's any way to do that other
than to actually root your concerns in
the concerns of the people you're
serving which is a challenging job to do
especially in a dwindling advertising
market but which i think is the only way
back to making people feel like you know
this person is actually serving me and I
think that's reinforced by the business
model you know there's a reason that
surgery isn't paid for by advertisements
there's an article that's famous in
startup circles that describes what
really matters in a startups culture and
the premise is you know you can have
whatever set of values on the wall but
at the end of the day it's who gets
fired and who gets hired and who gets
promoted there's about 90 percent of
what people observe to decide how
actually to behave here and so if I have
a big poster that says you know we're
gonna act with integrity but people who
don't act with integrity are getting
fired or not getting fired doesn't
matter right so I think this is actually
a really good analogy for why these
social spaces are so confusing because
essentially what we have on Facebook and
on Twitter is a system where the same
things that get you promoted also get
you fired in other words being
sensational being conflict oriented
being you know rallying a tribe to your
side all of these are the things that
elevate you as someone who's on facebook
or someone who's on Twitter it's it's a
thing that drives engagement is a thing
that you know that there rewards you up
to a point and then all of a sudden you
know you're banned from the platform if
you're Alex Jones or you're someone
who's just a little bit too incendiary I
think what these platforms you know need
to do because there's no such thing as
neutral
and because the values that get you
promoted are really out of sync with the
values that get you fired or demoted you
know the only thing that that these
platforms can do is kind of state their
principles and be consistent about them
both in terms of who gets to be heard by
lots of people and who doesn't get to be
heard at all and I think that's a
challenging position for them because
you know some people will disagree with
whatever values they state if Twitter
decides that respectful conversation as
one of their top values that's going to
privilege some kinds of conversation
over other kinds of conversation it's
going to be better for some users than
others but at least it's a transparent
principle that we can all understand
that can be used to decide you know what
what the principles what the physics of
this system are and right now I think we
have this very confusing set of
conflicting signals where where things
are totally out of whack
[Music]
you